لذلك اجتمعت اليوم المجموعة الاستشارية التقنية
المعنية بتطور الفيروسات لمناقشة
المتغير b11529
لمناقشة ما نفهمه حول هذا
المتغير وما إذا كان ينبغي تصنيفها على
أنها متغير مثير للاهتمام أو متغير من
الاهتمامات
بناءً على المعلومات التي لدينا
بشكل خاص من جنوب
إفريقيا  لقد نصحنا بضرورة تصنيف هذا المتغير
على أنه متغير
مثير للقلق ، لذلك نعلن اليوم عن
b11529 باعتباره متغيرًا مثيرًا للقلق يسمى
omicron ، لذا تم تسمية omicron b11529 على أنه متغير مثير للقلق
لأنه يحتوي على بعض
الخصائص ذات الصلة ، حيث
يحتوي هذا المتغير على عدد كبير  من
الطفرات وبعض هذه الطفرات
لها بعض الخصائص المقلقة في الوقت
الحالي ، هناك العديد من الدراسات التي
تجري حاليًا وهناك الكثير من العمل
الجاري في جنوب إفريقيا وفي بلدان أخرى
لتوصيف
المتغير نفسه بشكل أفضل من حيث
القابلية للانتقال من حيث الشدة
و  أي تأثير على إجراءاتنا المضادة
مثل استخدام العلاجات التشخيصية
أو
اللقاحات حتى الآن  هناك القليل من المعلومات ولكن
هذه الدراسات جارية ، لذا فنحن بحاجة
إلى أن يتوفر للباحثين الوقت الكافي
لتنفيذها والذين سيبلغون
الجمهور وشركائنا والدول الأعضاء
بمجرد حصولنا على مزيد من المعلومات بمجرد
تصنيف المتغير على أنه متغير
مثير للقلق  من المهم حقًا أن
يكون لدينا cyrus kobe جيد للمراقبة في
جميع أنحاء العالم بما في ذلك
التسلسل الجيني الأفضل لأننا نريد أن نكون
قادرين على اكتشاف هذا المتغير حيث يتم
تداوله ، ومن المهم أيضًا إجراء
دراسات جارية في
هذا المجال للنظر في أي مجموعات
وأيضًا الدراسات اللازمة في
المختبر لمعرفة ما إذا كانت هناك أي
تغييرات في الخطورة ، أي تغييرات في
تأثيرنا على العلاجات التشخيصية أو
اللقاحات ، ستجتمع المجموعة الاستشارية الفنية
لتطور الفيروس
بانتظام حول omicron وسوف يستغرق الأمر
أيامًا إلى أسابيع من أجل  بعض هذه الدراسات
التي يتعين إجراؤها ، من المهم حقًا
إجراء هذه الدراسات وإتمامها بشكل
شامل  بمجرد حصولنا على مزيد من
المعلومات ، سننشر هذه
المعلومات ولكن من المهم أن
تعرف أن هناك الكثير الذي يمكنك القيام
به للحفاظ على سلامتك أنت وأحبائك ،
نحن نتفهم أن الناس
قلقون ، الشيء الجيد هو أن لدينا
أنظمة مراقبة  في جميع أنحاء العالم
لاكتشاف هذه المتغيرات بسرعة كبيرة ،
تم اكتشاف هذا المتغير قبل بضعة أسابيع
وبالفعل يشارك العلماء الأبحاث
معنا في المعلومات حتى نتمكن من
اتخاذ إجراء ما هو مهم حقًا
كفرد لتقليل
تعرضك للإجراءات التي تم إثباتها
للجمهور  لم تكن الإجراءات الصحية أكثر أهمية من أي وقت مضى ،
إبعاد ارتداء
القناع والتأكد من أنه فوق
أنفك وفمك بأيدٍ نظيفة ،
وتأكد من تجنب الأماكن المزدحمة
التي كانت في الغرف حيث توجد
تهوية جيدة وعندما يحين دورك احصل على
التطعيم